مرتضى منصور يهدد بحبس اتحاد الكره
المصريه تعني البش يتحدثوا لي اول مره من
خلف القضبان وصديقته بكي تواجه اتهامات
بانها خربت بيوت هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه
اخبارنا الرياضيه من مصر حيث التفاعل رواد
السوشيال ميديا اليوم مع الهجوم الذي شلهم
مرتضى منصور رئيس الزمالك على رئيس واعضاء
مجلس اداره اتحاد الكره المحلي لتاكيده في
تصريحاته عبر قناه النادي مقاداته لهم
والمطالبه بحبسهم وعزلهم من مناصبهم الامر
لم ينتهي هنا رئيس الزمالك فجر ايضا
مفاجاه اخرى تمثل في احتماليه عوده فيريرا
المدرب السابق لتدريب الفريق الاول بعد
مباراه واحده فقط من اقالته وعلل مرتضى
منصور الامر بان الجهاز الفني قد تامر على
المدرب البرتغالي وهدفعه لايقته
خرج البرازيلي داني الفيس عن صمته وتحدث
من داخل السجن الذي يتواجد فيه حاليا في
اسبانيا ففي تصريحات نشرتها صحيفه ماركه
الاسبانيه على لساني لاعب برشلونه السابق
اشارت فيها الى ان داني حاليا لا يشعر
ابدا بالخوف او الرعب بل العكس تماما يثق
بقدرته محاميه على اطلاق سراحه من السجن
في غضون شهر وبحسب المنشور فان اعرف مصر
على براءته من تهمه الاغتصاب وانما حدث في
الملهى تم بموافقه الفتاه التي كان على
علاقه مسبقه بها وقام بالتكتم عليها لخوفه
من معرفه زوجته بخيانته لها
ننتقل الى زين الدين زيدان حيث كشفت
تقارير اعلاميه ان المدرب الفرنسي يرفض
الانتقال والتدريب في الدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز وبحسب صحيفه موندو ديبورتيفو
الاسباني فان زيدان ليس منفتحا على فكره
الانتقال الى انجلترا وقياده فريقا في
البريميرليج بسبب حاجز اللغه وارتبط صاحب
الخمسين عاما بالانتقال الى اكثر من نادي
الانجليزي في الاشهر الاخيره من بينها
تشيلسي
الختام مع كلاراشيه صديقتي الجديده التي
باتت حديثه المنزل بعد حملته هجوم واسعه
عشانها عشاق شاكيرا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بهاشتاج خرابت البيوت ابنته
الثالثه والعشرين عاما تمر حاليا بازمه
النفسيه الصعبه بحسب تقارير اعلاميه
اسبانيا دفعتها للهروب الى منزل والديها
منذ ثمانيه ايام والعمل فيه
العالم والعمل فيه من بعد هربا من الصحافه
واعين المتطفلين وبحسب المنشور فانك لارا
لا تملك الشخصيه القويه التي تكفي لمواجهه
لمواجهه الحرب التي تتعرض لها في الوقت
الحالي من مضايقات ونعتها بخرابه البيوت
في الشوارع والاماكن العامه بعد التعرف
عليه عليها